hello YouTube welcome back to let's play
amnesia the Dark Descent this is part 12
and as you can see my vision is still
royally [ __ ] up but I will press on
all right so far
I've stuck myself with a needle that was
in a dead guy's head I went through the
sewers which wasn't particularly water
mastery but still kind of sucked and now
um I'm going down here okay hey now I'm
going into the sewers that wasn't the
sewers before right yep okay what can I
expect in the sewers well I'm guessing
there's gonna be monsters that's just a
wild wild guess but that's my guess
right down see mushrooms
oh boy water sewer without water I guess
ah no
huh
you don't scare me I'm too brave I'm
just gonna go in there the opposite
direction you did yeah yeah it seems
like a good plan whoo
this looks fun I'm sure that got ripped
open by natural causes but I wanted to
go up there and get out of this sewer
now whatever move it forward where we
got here
slam
oil I got lots of
what my journal said something got ready
thanks to levers control on noisy
machine
good quiet
oh yeah that's nice and quiet Oh what's
up there
Oh dead rat live rat dead okay ha ha ha
no door uh-oh
by the poisonous mushrooms yeah oh
that's a good idea
Oh music stops shoot shoosh shoosh music
be quiet quiet he's gonna leave me alone
that's right
[Music]
all right okay
see we can all get along yep
moving on me big brave me not afraid of
monster okay
okay
they lose tinderbox ah oh there we go
I'm so strong Oh take this pipe Greek
the monsters over their heads if they
have heads I don't even know half the
time
okay yeah that hurt aah
Oh ha damn
by Alma uh-huh smart I am Todd da lock
it ain't no thing
all right moving forward yes yep go dead
rats ba oh hey hello buddy
oh oh oh oh shut up Alexander would you
look at this thing what the [ __ ]
happened to his face oh they all like
that oh all your legs are basically bone
oh that's gross
how can this thing even hurt me and I
didn't matter I'm still running away
from it no the whale again moving
forward backwards moving backwards
backwards movement
aah-ha-aah don't come up this way oh wow
the dark ah oh take your friend I didn't
hurt him I swear
take out go away no one likes you
your friend is dead please just go off
and kill yourself everybody shush shush
yeah that's right walk away hey you look
different than the other guy
oh right I got this aha maybe I did kill
your friend what you gonna do bad
nothing walk away
oh right moving on more mushrooms pipes
lots of stuff Oh
what do always
nope nope ah there's another way
but hello
ah I see ha ha ha what is that
uh-huh oh it's ugly yeah we'll get it
get it
[Music]
ah huh just don't come back back here
yep
ha ha I'm the man I'm the man with the
plan
ha ha mokey the way you ain't got
nothing
yeah I won obviously I am the winner am
i climbing out of well here whatever I
still won
he ain't got nothing on me yeah is it
breaking don't break don't fall back
down oh yeah okay oh fudge again it's
budging
that's budging right there you budged
you knew what was good for you didn't
you
right what's this then oil
I don't need oil at least not right now
ha yeah of course there's always
something wrong nothing remember working
right off the bat of course I can't stop
sweating and shaking so what the warding
ritual was not something of a sane mind
Oh boohoo I did not even realize the
dungeon was still in you saw water
Aleksandr had his servants bring one of
the prisoners a murderer he told me yeah
bright Alexander made all the
arrangements but he said I had to
perform the ritual in order to have the
right effect oh he said the shadow could
be led astray by the blood of another
sure thing man killing the man would
provide us precious time sounds good to
me what else could I do
nothing Alexander said it had to be done
it did he is saving my life well that's
questionable have the luxury of argument
yeah you don't know right moving on that
chains again about Jana Rama using my
tinderboxes wisely what's in here
whole lot of nothing ooh a big stairwell
come on out I'm unarmed oh there's
definitely got to be something under
this stairwell oh there has to be yay
tinderboxes anything else knows it
ah this stairwell is gigantic and they
only have two tinderboxes the syringe no
I can't feel anything your life is safe
oh but no probably not
ah whoa what is that oh [ __ ]
dead body asked
[Music]
but oh yeah hey whoa aah oh no no oh
wait boys oh you're you Agrippa yeah I
guess Daniel
no not like that don't laugh at me and
the line you [ __ ]
yes I didn't say that huh
about that what is so great about this
orb I think I'd have a better name than
a norm
really tell the truth by all of you seek
out the pieces of the broken home wait
no wait I thought there was only one
[Music]
okay fine trust you
who's there
tinderbox it was that you know whatever
who's there Oh tough mess me no no no
more down meat yeah me like meat me much
meat no I'm not sure shove it right into
my heart
Damascus Rose office yeah well my memory
but my body remembers
folios yeah even though pipeline it
means back yeah whatever you're crazy
well these people were in here we're
obviously completely well deserved
prisoners Oh weird but whatever I've
seen weirder in that place okay
oh oh very cool
yeah yeah as normal
who's there I heard voices what's you
doing yeah give me a Tim Tim Tim
tinderbox all right I gotta stop it here
but I'm gonna pick it rub right back
with part 13 of amnesia the Dark Descent
don't go anywhere